today's question is from Jessie now in
New Jersey they were having a very hard
time trying to get on track with
everything including starting our
emergency fund what can we do when we
are so behind that we can not even catch
up we're about two months behind on all
bills it's causing a lot of stress on
our marriage or kids
we're tired of living this way but we
feel like we're in so much debt in so
deep that we can't get out yeah I just
think it gets really really scary when
you're in a situation like that and part
of what's scary is the sense that you're
stuck part of what's scary is you're
overwhelmed and let's stop and pull one
segment out of this thing and talk about
that for a second we're two months
behind on our bills and it's causing us
so much stress on our marriage
and kids being behind on your bills
should not affect your kids they
shouldn't know about it you don't need
to tell your five-year-old you're behind
the lights that's not their problem
that's your problem and you can tell the
kids no but you don't have to give them
a big long reason to why those a
complete sentence no but don't pass off
the you know don't pass off the stress
to the kids
now let's look at the rest of this what
do you do when you're completely
overwhelmed and terrified and feel stuck
I've been there some of y'all know what
I'm talking about you've been there too
and you it is no fun okay here's how you
fix it you have to begin to take control
of what you can take control of you have
an income let's make sure that that
first is being controlled and that's
called the budget
now you do not have to be able to pay
everything to do a budget all a budget
is as you're telling the money that you
do have where it is going to go and so
when you can't pay everything which
catching everything up in one month
would be paying everything right when
you can't pay everything then you've got
to say well the money that we have we're
gonna do the most we can do with that
and for this month that's all we can do
so
you prioritize it you make enough to buy
food you do not make enough to eat out
so we're not going to restaurants but we
are going to the grocery store and we're
going to feed our family and we're gonna
cook from scratch because it's healthier
and it costs less so there we go food
you make enough to do that check put
that one down put a food budget down
write that number down you can do that
you make enough to pay your lights and
water and if you're behind on them you
catch them all up this month before you
do anything else after you eat get
current on your lights get current on
your water now if you have a $600 a
month cable bill because you have NFL
super duper pooper-scooper or whatever
then cancel all that crap but I'm
talking about water and lights and gas
to eat okay now I don't really give a
ripple whether you can see Downton Abbey
or not but I am more concerned about you
having lights and water on and gas to
eat if it's gas heat okay so you pay
your basic necessities food and
utilities you make enough to do that and
get current on them right now
number three is shelter now you pay your
rent it doesn't matter if you pay your
rent and you can't sleep there because
there's no heat so you got to put heat
in the place okay so you pay your rent
if you're behind on your rent before you
move on to number four you catch up on
your rent number four transport
you current on the car and you keep gas
in the car now if that takes all your
money and you can pay nothing else this
month oh well now I mean but think about
this if you got a place to live that's
current you're not gonna get evicted
your utilities are all current and
they're not gonna get cut off and you
have food and the car is not gonna get
repo'd and it's got gas in it so you can
go to work you live to fight another
month that's very essential that you get
through those and you do make enough to
get through those but you've been
feeding the other monsters and the other
monsters are the people that call and
scream at you and in order for them to
not scream at you you pay them don't pay
them MasterCard is not in front of your
children eating MasterCard can jump in
the creek Discover bondage can sit over
there and suck its thumb we're not
giving them any money
American Express can definitely bite my
ankle seriously right they can sit over
on the sidelines right now until you get
your food shelter clothing and utilities
and transportation taking care of call
the student loan people tell Sallie Mae
she is on hardship deferral she's not
getting a dime then you begin to
continue to work down the list and you
get to who you can get to in order of
importance yet you just work the list
and work the list and work the list now
if you got a big pile of debt and you
don't see any hope past those things
then it's time to start talking about
what we can sell and what we can do to
create an income I mean you may have to
amputate the Tahoe you may have this big
stinking car payment that's killing you
you may have to take like six extra jobs
and drive for uber or deliver pizzas or
clean somebody's toilets on the weekends
I don't know what you're going to do but
my grandmother used to say there's a
great place to go when you're broke to
work increase the income make the money
behave take care of your necessities
first we call that the four walls of
your house
when you have the four walls of your
house protected the people inside are
safe and they're dry then you live to
fight another day
the powders dried I've had go to battle
as they say you gotta have the Gunpowder
dry or it won't work right so we got to
have a plan we get all those things laid
out it's step by step by step by step
see I'm feeling better about your
situation already because I don't even
know your numbers but I've done this for
30 years and I almost I'd save 99.9
percent of the time I sit down with
someone that has a job they can take
care of food shelter clothing
transportation and utilities and by the
way you don't need clothing you got
clothing just wear what you got and if
you got to buy the kids a pair of shoes
because their toes are coming through
something that's fine but you only be
buying a bunch of clothing you're
clothed most of you got enough clothing
last we're not trying to make a fashion
statement right now be bold we're trying
to survive so I don't care you'll get to
that stuff later I'm talking about this
month where you don't feel hopeless
anymore where you have a sense of
traction where you see a light at the
end of the tunnel that's not an oncoming
train and when you've got food your
lights and water are current and they're
not about to be cut off you've got your
rent current you're not about to get
evicted or foreclosed on on your home
your car is not about to get repo'd
you've got those basic things done and
you can get most of that done in one or
two months
if you quit paying everything else I
mean you get behind on your credit cards
further well so what we'll get back to
them later they get behind on Sallie Mae
further so what what's she gonna do just
get uglier well get ugly I hang up the
phone I can stop you from talking
[Music]
just you know hit that little end button
they quit talking it's an amazing thing
and don't take a bunch of crap off these
people you do the best you can do but
work extra sell stuff get this budget
balanced get your every dollar app it's
free to download onto your phone you can
do this it's how you eat an elephant
bite at a time you see I gave you a
step-by-step clear path the next thing
you do is you get current and then and
only then once your current did you
start your baby steps but you got a
little while before you do that it might
be three months for you get there sell
stuff extra jobs take care of the
necessities first this is the Dave
Ramsey show